au mois d'août c'est annie pas croire
c'est inespéré c'est presque miraculeux
les villes les grandes villes
redeviennent raisonnables elle ne frise
plus la crise de nerfs la crise
cardiaque la folie furieuse
l'été les villes rajeunissent elles
deviennent de petits villages dans
chaque quartier comme en province il y a
un bout chez un boulanger un charcutier
puisque les autres sont fermés on se
reprend on se surprend à parler avec son
voisin le seul celui qui reste au
carrefour des rues les rares
automobilistes magnanime détendu
courtois vous laisse passer avec le
sourire on croit rêver
on peut marcher dans la ville le nez en
l'air ou presque et ce qui est encore le
plus extraordinaire entendre le bruit de
ses propres pas mais la folie est
ailleurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle s'est déplacée tout simplement
cette fameuse société de consommation
dont on parle tant à transporter
ailleurs ses plaies dans ses bagages sur
les toits des voitures dans les malles
arrière elle n'a rien oublié ni les
embouteillages ils sont la superbe une
demi-heure de bouchons pour atteindre
l'entrée des villages beaucoup plus
encore pour en sortir
la promiscuité des transports en commun
c'est sur la plage qu'on la retrouve
parquet serré compressé on transpire en
groupe et on se bagarre pour une place
[Musique]
la pollution bien entendu est au rendez
vous le mazout est en prime et fait
désormais partie de la panoplie des
vacances le bruit la queue au restaurant
la mauvaise humeur des serveurs les
maladies de la ville on les retrouve ici
en bloc
elle frôle de l'ale les bateaux des
milliardaires
restez chez vous ne partez pas ou alors
plus tard beaucoup plus tard quand ils
seront remplis regard de la ville
découvre ses charmes
vous pouvez même si le coeur vous en dit
montée à pied les champs elysées tout
comme notre président de la république
la ville est à vous l'été vous en donne
les clés
ne partez pas c'est un conseil que vous
ne suivrez pas bien sûr parce qu'il ya
le ciel le soleil et la mer et que bien
peu résiste à la près d'un bronzage
intensif bronzage sacré signes
extérieurs évident des vacances réussies
et puis et puis il faut bien avouer que
le spectacle que nous offre les plages à
la mode celui d'une très jolies filles
aux seins nus
évidemment cela ne court pas l'air
[Musique]